how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and of course everything relating
to the MCU today we're going to be
talking about the Wanda vision series
now unfortunately many of Marvel Studios
as current projects have been put on
hold
production for many of the movies and TV
shows that are coming to Disney Plus
have been postponed due to the corona
virus but even though right now there's
no filming going on with all of the
projects at Marvel Studios they're still
managing to do some work like editing
remotely so they are still managing to
work on the one division series remotely
a little bit to keep it as on track as
possible and today we have a leak that
of course comes from an anonymous person
who says that they worked on the set and
they've leaked a description on what
they saw from a few episodes on the set
so let's go over what they saw and break
it all down and if you're new be sure to
subscribe with notifications turned on
to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and I'm also
starting a weekly giveaways next week so
like with all leaks take this with a
grain of salt we have no way of
verifying if it's true or not it was
posted on 4chan and the avengers in game
+ infinity war leaks that ended up being
100% true were posted on 4chan as well
because it's a place where you can go
and post things anonymously and if
you're somebody who's working on the set
of Marvel Studios you're gonna want to
post it anonymously so you don't get
fired so it could be true but of course
take it with a grain of salt and also if
you are trying to avoid any and all
spoilers here's your last warning click
away now so the description starts off
by saying there are some are really
fantastic psychedelic pictures I worked
on several scenes focusing mainly on the
formation of fractals from the
surrounding area for example the scene
where Kathryn Hahn grabs Wanda from the
reality she finds herself in and it was
Brady Bunch's pastel from the 80s and
from the real world which is dark and
chaotic another scene in which kat
dennings dresses as a cleaner and dr.
strange forces her into an astral
projection so she can exit the role she
was housed in the show seems to be half
sitcom and half blockbuster the last
scene was of their living room and of
their kids but everything exploded
seeing many different versions of vision
their children Randall Park Wanda yells
and explodes with different dimensions
and red
vice so there are seemingly three scenes
to break down here
the scene where Kathryn Hahn who is
widely believed to be plain Agatha
Harkness grabs Wanda from a reality a
scene with dr. strange and kat dennings
and a final scene with vision Randall
Park and Wanda exploding and based off
of the tiny little teaser that Marvel
Studios gave us for the one division
series during the Super Bowl and based
off of the other information that we
know about the film we have a pretty
good idea of what's going on here so
let's start with the first scene it's
described as Kathryn Hahn grabbing Wanda
from the reality she finds herself in
and it was a Brady Bunch's pastel from
the 80s and from the real world which is
dark and chaotic so first things first
which we assumed was going to happen in
this film and is pretty much all but
confirmed is that Wanda is creating
different realities but the key
character here is Agatha Harkness I
would be absolutely shocked if Kathryn
Hahn was not playing Agatha Harkness we
even have leaked photos of her in a
witch's costume
now Agatha Harkness is a pretty big deal
not only does she have a major
connection to the Fantastic Four and
Franklin Richards one of the most
powerful mutants that the Marvel
Universe has ever seen she's also
connected to Doctor Doom but she also
trained Wanda and that is most likely
what is happening here in the one
division series and in the comics Agatha
actually does create an alternate
reality for Wanda to help her cope with
the loss of her kids but what's most
likely going on here is that Agatha is
teaching Wanda how to create new
realities because the last time we left
her she was so powerful that she almost
killed
Thanos however we haven't seen anything
that would lead us to believe that she
knows how to create a new reality so
Agatha's main point in this series is
most likely going to be helping Wanda
actually develop which like powers like
she has in the comics now in the brief
little teaser that we got for the one
division series we did see different
realities take place and this league
mentions one specifically which is the
Brady Bunch pastel background which we
definitely saw now this reality is a
world to her where vision is still alive
and she has kids but let's jump to the
last scene where it says everything
explodes so it's very possible and
widely expected that Wanda is going to
go a little bit crazy in the show it's
of what happened during the House of M
storyline it's a very complicated story
line but to summarize it let's just say
that she kind of goes crazy and creates
this new reality
so right now Wanda is living in this
sort of perfect reality where she has a
husband who is human we know this
because we've seen the promo photo from
Marvel directly of vision being in human
form and in this reality she has two
kids
but sadly eventually she is going to
realize that her kids aren't real vision
isn't real he's not back to life and
this may cause her to have somewhat of a
breakdown and explode as it says here
the last scene is in the living room
with their kids but everything exploded
and it says Wanda yells and explodes
with different dimensions and red lights
now the red lights are clearly the
energy that she's going to project we
see her energy all the time and it's
always red but it says that she's going
to explode with different dimensions
meaning she could destroy all of the
realities that she created now when she
explodes and all of the realities that
she has created get destroyed there are
two things that could happen one is
simply that everything that she created
and everything and everyone inside of
those realities when they get destroyed
are completely gone her kids vision any
other characters are completely gone or
they take from the House of M storyline
and some of the characters that she
created in these new realities her kids
her husband vision come into her main
reality this is kind of what happened in
house of M Wanda combined at two
realities and the end result was some
people who were dead before but were
alive in the new reality stayed alive
when both realities combined and this
could possibly be what happens in the
Wanda vision series
Wanda will create a family vision will
be brought back to life and the two of
them will have kids and these could come
back into the main reality it's also
widely believed that her brother
Quicksilver is going to be returning for
this show as well there have been some
audition scripts leaked for the roles of
the children of Wanda and vision and in
the script it mentions their uncle
well since vision was created by Tony
Stark we know that he doesn't have any
brothers or sisters so the only brother
that Wanda has is Pedro
so clearly while bringing vision back to
life and creating kids for herself in an
alternate reality she brings her brother
back as well which makes perfect sense
why wouldn't she so when Wanda
loads and all of the realities
eventually blow up perhaps Quicksilver
her children and vision will come back
to the main reality with her but then we
have another scene that involves dr.
strange and Darcy
it says kat dennings who is the actress
that plays Darcy is dressed as a cleaner
and dr. strange forces her into an
astral projection so she can exit the
role she was Houston now this is a tiny
bit confusing but here's what I think is
happening now kat dennings has been
confirmed to be in the one division
series for a while now but the question
is what role will she play is she going
to be working for shield is she going to
be working for dr. Erik Selvig still we
know that Jimmy woo is going to be
playing a SHIELD agent and we also know
that sword is going to be around in the
one division series as well so right now
her role is kind of unknown but one
thing is for sure based off of this
description of the scene she's trying to
sneak into the sanctum sanctorum for
whatever reason we do not know but
Doctor Strange being the master of the
mystic arts that he is detects her and
sends her into an astral projection the
ancient one did this to dr. strange when
he first showed up and she did it again
to the Hulk / Bruce Banner in Avengers
endgame now there's not much information
to go off of here but it could be
assumed that Darcy is somehow working
with Wanda in some capacity whether
that's working with shield to try and
stop Wanda from exploding and creating
different realities or affecting the
reality that they all currently live in
or somehow she's a friend of hers but
what seems to be happening here is that
Darcy is trying to look for something
that dr. strange may have possibly a
relic that could help Wanda she could
even be working for Agatha Harkness
because one thing is for sure Wanda is
going to appear in dr. strange in the
multiverse of madness now a lot of us
didn't think that dr. strange would
appear in the one division series but if
the series is going to lead up to
multiverse of madness it does make sense
now it seems very clear that Wanda is
going to be creating problems for the
multiverse since she's going to be
creating different realities and based
off of the title multiverse of madness
we can tell that dr. strange is going to
have his hands full with different
realities so what's happening with Wanda
in the one division series is going to
directly tie into and affect dr. strange
- now the one very interesting thing
about the one division series and
multiverse of madness is
in the house of M comic storyline which
seems to play a big part in the upcoming
one division series the x-men and
mutants were very heavily involved in
fact in the storyline Wanda is so
powerful that she says no more mutants
and 90% of the mutant population is
wiped away and we've had many reports
that we could see mutants in multiverse
of madness
so while Marvel is looking for a way to
introduce the mutants they could have
settled on possibly using Wanda and
Doctor Strange to introduce them there's
been a report by Mikey Sutton that the
Illuminati could appear in multiverse of
madness which of course has several
mutants involved there's also been a
report that Namor could appear in
multiverse of madness as well and really
since we're dealing with infinite
different universes the possibilities
are endless but based off of these
leaked descriptions of some scenes from
the one division series that we got one
thing seems to be quite clear and that
is that Wanda is clearly going to have a
big impact on Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and the entire MCU
moving forward whether that's creating
mutants in the future or creating the
multiverse that is going to be blown
into madness by her exploding but let me
know what you think about these scenes
that were leaked we know that vision and
Wanda's kids are going to be in the
series but do you think that they will
stay in the main reality and what role
do you think she's going to play and
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU for live updates don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof